wenn aus einem kreis ein quadrat werden
soll sträubt sich die natur das ist in
der politik nicht anders
egal ob die cdu eine klare richtung
einschlägt oder die ganzen inhaltliche
breite einer volkspartei integrieren
möchte mit beiden wegen könnte sie nicht
glücklich werden
ein dilemma in denen die partei
feststeckt führungskrise und welche
richtung die cdu jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix-runde herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauer bei uns meine gäste im studio
frau professor andrea römmele ist bei
uns kommunikations und
politikwissenschaftlerin an der hertie
school hier in berlin
professor werner patzelt emeritierter
politikwissenschaftler an der
technischen universität dresden
sie sind aber noch mehr sie könnte sich
ja seit jahren den kurs von angela
merkel und jetzt auch von kaka oder
haben in kritisiert sie haben die
sächsische cdu im wahlkampf 2009 10
beraten im landtagswahlkampf und sie
sind mitglied der werte union
michael brücker ist bei uns
chefredakteur des medien start ups mit
japan ihr und christoph ploß ist
stellvertretender landesvorsitzender der
cdu hamburg und mitglied des bundestages
hat los sind sie gerade dann
cdu-mitglied auch das bin ich
grundsätzlich immer gerne es gibt
natürlich immer auf und ab in seiner
langen geschichte das ist ja völlig klar
und klar ist auch dass es in den
vergangenen tagen nicht besonders gut
gelaufen ist und dass viren schnell
rütteln müssen einen klaren kurs wieder
bekommen müssen und auch die
personalaufstellung aus meiner sicht
relativ zügig angehen müssen programme
sieht man gerade an der cdu wie vorher
bei der spd dass die zeit der
volksparteien zu ende geht ja sicherlich
die cdu wird einen ähnlichen weg gehen
zumindest jetzt im nächsten halben jahr
ja wie wir es bei der spd gesehen haben
die ganz große frage wird bei der cdu
die führungsfrage sein die ja auch
einher geht damit wie die cdu dann
letztendlich ausgerichtetes aber das
trudeln der der cdu die instabilität die
wir jetzt sehen die wir die cdu jetzt
sicherlich ein paar monate begleiten
patzelt thüringen zeigt doch eines wie
ungewöhnlich für die cdu die nähe zur
afg ist so ist es die afg ist toxisch
für jeden denn ihre gerät deswegen war
es ja auch eine so große politische
torheit zeitungs die cdu überhaupt
rechts von sich eine neue partei groß
werden zu lassen und sämtliche warnungen
in den wind zu schlagen
politisches gelände an eine
rechtspopulistische partei überhaupt
freizugeben
herr brücke äquidistanz zwischen der kfd
und gleichermaßen zu den linken
das ist ja ein parteitagsbeschluss der
cdu quasi ein programmatischer grundsatz
kann die cdu diesen grundsatz wirklich
aufgeben ohne dass es die partei
zerreißt das problem an dem beschluss
ist dass er zu hart gefasst ist die
berühmte hufeisen theorie japan wird das
besser wissen gleiche distanz zu den
beiden rennen er erweist sich in der
realität im konkreten im kommunalen eben
als teilweise nicht handelbar mono
ramelow ist ein rechter bei den linken
der ist alles andere als ein
bürgerschreck insofern wenn man wenn man
stoisch beschlüsse fasst in einer
ausdifferenzierten individualisierten
gesellschaftlichen landschaft dann muss
man irgendwann eigene beschlüsse
korrigieren gefahr autoritätsverlust
oder man muss sie optimieren und die cdu
wird diesen beschluss optimieren müssen
egal wer es an der spitze macht man
kommt es zu dieser optimierung ich
glaube nicht dass wir das optimieren
werden denn für die cdu ist wirklich
ganz grundlegend dass wir sowohl
linksextremismus als auch
rechtsextremismus bekämpfen
wir sind gegründet worden als partei
weil wir ein bollwerk gegen kommunismus
sein wollten wir wollten immer auch ein
bollwerk gegen faschismus und
nationalsozialismus sein
und natürlich ist das gerade für uns in
deutschland was wir mit dem
nationalsozialismus in unserem land
erlebt haben etwas ganz furchtbares und
einzigartig das gar keine frage und
natürlich gibt es bei der linkspartei
personen wo man sagt na ja das sind
vielleicht bessere sozialdemokraten
sie haben das umgekehrt aber auch bei
der fdp die menschen haben die
vielleicht früher mal in der cdu waren
was ich aber auch diesen gemäßigten
vorwerfe ist dass sie teilweise mit
extremisten paktieren zusammenarbeiten
und vor allem auch extremistische
strömungen in ihren reihen dulden
und wer so etwas tut der kann für die
cdu nie ein partner sache was machen sie
bei jungen leuten die 35 96 sind und die
linken im osten führen die haben die die
wende gerade als kleines kind erlebt
irgendwann ist diese ddr unrechtsstaat
analogien nicht mehr tragfähig wenn die
junge menschen in ämtern sind und
pragmatische linke politik machen ja
weil wir reden ja im land immer zu recht
von einer erinnerungskultur die wir
pflegen müssen das heißt wir müssen
sagen was ist im nationalsozialismus
passiert und mit sich so etwas nie
wiederholt
das gleiche gilt aber natürlich auch für
die ddr was dort
und haben deckmantel des sozialismus des
kommunismus geschehen ist das ist doch
auch furchtbar mauertote menschen die
drangsaliert wurden in der
meinungsfreiheit beschränkt wurden da
kann doch nicht sagen die partei die
sich noch in dieser geistigen nachfolger
sieht da gibt es jetzt vielleicht leute
die nicht mehr direkt was damit zu tun
haben und deswegen arbeitet man den
zusammengetragen ja dieses gedankengut
teilweise weiter und oder akzeptieren
dass es menschen in ihren reihen gibt
die dieses gedankengut haben und
deswegen finde ich es auch so wichtig
dass die cdu wirklich sowohl nach ganz
links als auch nach ganz rechts eine
klare linie zieht dürfen ein haken weil
ich wollte mich ganz gerne zu dieser
richtungsdiskussion kommen wir noch sie
damit sozusagen ich wollte das gespräch
jetzt auch laufen lassen aber ich würde
gerne noch ein stück zurückgehen und wir
kommen aber gleich auch zu diesem thema
wieder zurück was da gestern passiert
ist stand die parteiführung durch
annegret kramp karrenbauer von anfang an
unter einem schlechten und guten stern
warum also sie hatte sie hatte zumindest
sie hatte einen sehr schlechten start
ich meine natürlich ist es erstmal aus
demokratie theoretische perspektive ein
schöner prozess wenn sich mehrere
kandidaten zu einer wahl des
vorsitzenden stellen
das ist im prinzip erst mal zu begrüßen
dann hat sie die wahl sehr knapp
gewonnen und letztendlich hat sie die
ganze zeit mindestens einen und
eigentlich mehrere möchtegern parallel
vorsitzende gehabt das ist das erste
also ein ein wackeliger start und dann
hat sie auch ein fettnäpfchen nach dem
anderen bedient sie ist kommunikativ
auch nie hier in dieser berliner medien
blase angekommen man kann diese blase
jetzt finden wie man möchte aber sie ist
nun mal da und sie folgt bestimmten
regeln und die muss man lernen und da
hat sie sich immer sehr schwer damit
getan und was letzte woche der umgang
noch ganz sagen dass sie kommt ja von
hier aus gesehen ungefähr der gleichen
gegend wie kurt beck der grund ein
bisschen weiter östlicher hat aber die
gleichen erfahrungen hier ja natürlich
und in einem kleinen bundesland wie dem
saarland bei frau kramp karrenbauer
rheinland pfalz ist etwas größer ist das
miteinander ein ganz anderes man kennt
alle journalisten
dann ist mit den meisten journalisten
auf du und du und es ist hier in der
berliner republik einfach etwas ganz
anderes das ist jetzt schon mehrfach
auch indirekt angesprochen wir das thema
führungsstärke führungskraft
führungsqualität da wir in
demokratischen parteien uns bewegen die
nicht autokratisch geführt werden können
was bedeutet das in der praxis
führungsqualität zu zeigen
führungsstärke was muss man da haben und
was hatte da möglicherweise ak nicht
in der praxis heißt führungsstärke ich
gehe in einen raum hinein die anderen
merken dass ich da bin und dass ich
sofort alles wie die eisen fall spät um
einen magneten herum auf mich ausrichtet
und dazu braucht man natürlich macht das
heißt vernetzung macht die unangefochten
ist dafür braucht man fachwissen das
auch in debatten sich immer wieder
erhärten kann und dafür braucht man
mediale unterstützung die man ja im
politische macht ziemlich leicht
umrechnen kann vieles von dem hat die ak
nicht und ihr hauptproblem war dass die
heimliche partei führerin im kanzleramt
saß die heimliche partei führerin die
zugleich der liebling eines großen teils
der medien und eines großen teils der
opposition ist dagegen dann in einer
partei führungsanspruch durchzusetzen wo
die zentrale frage die ist ob man den
märkischen kurs weiterfahren soll oder
ob man darauf achten soll ob nicht eine
politische konkurrenz auf einer
unangenehmen seite des politischen
spektrums erwächst das hatakka in jene
verzweifelte lage gebracht die die
erfurter vorgänge im grunde nur zur
explosion fahren das war dann der
auslöser gewesen wobei inzwischen sicher
nach den umfragen auch wieder liebling
der bevölkerung jedenfalls gilt als
beliebte beliebteste politikerin war
dies ja weit abgesagt und die ganze zeit
über hält sie sich sehr oben ich finde
interessant dass man sich jetzt auch die
kanzlerin und ihre ihre intervention aus
südafrika konzentrierten wirklichkeit
hat die kanzlerin ihr den raum gelassen
annegret kramp karrenbauer durfte in den
ersten zwölf monaten ihrer amtszeit
eigentlich sehr frei agieren die merkel
hat sich rausgehalten aus innenpolitisch
unter hatten und die sind natürlicher
autorität hat sie eben nicht gewonnen
das ist das was meine vorbilder es fing
mit geschichten an die europapolitischen
grundsatzpapier und wo die europäer vor
allem die franzosen sich die hände von
kopf zusammengeschlagen haben sondern
beschreibt die da auf und mit wem redet
die kommunikation ist macht andere kann
kaum hat es nicht geschafft
letzteres macht gelangt ein sehr
interessanter begriff dass man eben
versucht sofort unterstützer zu
positionen zu finden und das hat eine
frau kamen kann noch jenseits von angela
merkel nie erreicht
wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe er
platz sind sie eher ein anhänger von
friedrich merz habe nicht leicht auf dem
bundesparteitag 2018 gewählt man hatte
ja den eindruck dass dieses märz lager
das war knapp unterlegen war
diese wahl nie wirklich akzeptiere das
ging damit völlig absurd und gerüchten
los wann hätte die klimaanlage heiß
gestellt als märz geredet hat um sie ins
schwitzen zu bringen was er ja auch
getan hat aber möglicherweise nicht
wegen der klimaanlage war das auch ein
problem dass das knapp unterlegene märz
lage das einfach nicht verkraftet hat
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so ich fand
wir haben als cdu insgesamt akzeptiert
dass da eine demokratische wahl stadt
fahren es gab ein votum ich habe selber
friedrich merz gewählt aber auch gesagt
demokratisch anders ausgegangen beim
parteitag und habe auch wie viele andere
mit dran gewirkt dass sich das in eine
positive richtung entwickelt das finde
ich gehört auch in der demokratie dazu
weiß könnte man sagen dass man mal
unterliegt und dann muss man die seite
unterstützen die siegreich ist ich habe
auch persönlich ehrlicherweise kaum
störmanöver wahrgenommen in den
vergangenen monaten also wir haben im
vergleich auf geradezu spd daher kaum
eine große innerparteiliche spaltung
gehabt oder diskussionen gehabt oder
angriffe gehabt das ist war beim
koalitionspartner den sozialdemokraten
völlig anders ich glaube nur dass wir
auch tatsächlich in zukunft auf
friedrich merz nicht verzichten können
weil die cdu immer dank stark war wenn
sie nicht nur christlich soziale milieus
angesprochen hat und auch liberale
wirtschaftsliberale milieus sondern auch
die wertkonservativen begrüßt das ist ja
ein problem was eben professor patzelt
auch zurecht beschrieben hat dass wir im
moment eine afd neben der cdu haben wo
eigentlich wertkonservative wähler
teilweise hingegangen sind die wir als
cdu zurück gewinnen müssten
ich will nicht die nazis zurückgewinnen
oder diejenigen die rechtes gedankengut
mitbringen dass wenn wir als cdu nie
schaffen aber die wertkonservativen
diejenigen die irgendwo sorgen haben die
müssen wir als union ansprechen und ich
glaube dass das friedrich merz sehr gut
gelingen kann
zusammen mit anderen viren sparen oder
auch kassen denen man mein versprechen
gilt dass wir gleich zum thema richtung
und richtungs auseinandersetzung zurück
eine frage muss ich ihn stellen formelle
jetzt sind ja wenn man die möglichen
nachfolgekandidaten kanzlerkandidatur
und parteivorsitzende anguckt ja die
männer wieder unter sich
klappt das dann vielleicht besser das
und nicht die dass der nachfolger nicht
die gleiche erfahrung machen wir sagen
nein
also ich sehe mich ich sehe einfach
stürmischen zeiten entgegen ich möchte
einmal ganz kurz auf ihre aus auf ihren
aus aufführungen zu sprechen kommen und
es dann so ein bisschen verbinden
ich glaube frau kramp karrenbauer
beziehungsweise die cdu würde jetzt
besser dastehen wenn herr merz nach
seiner niederlage ein teamplayer gewesen
wäre wenn er eben den rechten rand der
cdu auch etwas bedient hätte unter einer
parteivorsitzenden frau kramp
karrenbauer das hat er nicht gemacht und
ich denke die neuausrichtung der cdu
wird nur in einem team klappen also mit
einem da gebe ich ihnen vollkommen recht
herr patzelt ist muss ein
ich benutze den begriff nicht ganz so
gerne aber ich glaube an dieser stelle
passt eine charismatische
führungspersönlichkeit seien die
menschen auch mitreißen kann und auf
einen weg mit nimmt es muss jemand sein
der aus der mitte heraus auch moderieren
kann und da ist meiner ansicht nach herr
merz wahrscheinlich zu polarisierend
aber er muss teil dieses teams sein weil
nur so können sie diese
unterschiedlichen flügel in der partei
bedient nur als team mit einer
charismatischen führungsperson
also ich glaube das polarisierende kann
sogar ein vorteil sein weil wir die
diskussion wieder von den rändern in die
politische mitte führen
nicht so wie wir das ja auch lange zeit
in der bundesrepublik erlebt haben also
und starke abgrenzung zwischen
sozialdemokraten und christdemokraten
und was ich sehr kritisch sehe mir
wirklich sorgen macht ist dass wir
derzeit bezieht die großen diskussionen
haben einmal zwischen der afd der einen
seite und dann zwischen der linkspartei
auf der anderen und teilweise auch mit
denen kommen die grünen noch dazu aber
dass die klassischen volksparteien nicht
mehr diese polarisierung darstellen und
da müssen wir wieder hin
und deswegen glaube ich würde auch eine
rückkehr von friedrich merz die
demokratische kultur insgesamt stärken
das heißt das modell
polarisierender charismatische
charismatiker steht jetzt im raum
ich würde bevor man über die person
spricht tatsächlich über das programm
sprechen ich finde nein nicht
polarisierung ist per se jetzt das
rezept programm um eine revitalisierung
der volksparteien hinzukriegen
die cdu wird eine richtungsentscheidung
treffen müssen und frau kramp
karrenbauer hat es ja versucht mit einem
werkstattgespräch zur migration das ist
und bleibt ein zentrales thema für die
konservative kernwählerschaft wie gehen
wir mit migration integration und wie
gehen wir mit dem außengrenzen europas
keiner spricht mehr drüber ist ein
herzensthema das ist der grund warum
bestimmte parteien im osten gewachsen
sind da kann man drum herum reden wie
man will wenn der neue vorsitzende oder
die neue vorsitzende dieses thema nicht
zentral von vorne führt und klare
beschlüsse herbeiführt vielleicht auch
noch zwei drei andere themen
wirtschaftliche lage wachstumspolitik
dann kann sich herauskristallisieren wer
der ideale mann oder eine frau zu führen
dieser partei ist aber ich glaube das
ist die richtungsentscheidung zwischen
dem bv prien und herrn günther und herrn
spahn und herrn lindemann da ist ein
tiefer graben in dieser partei das
können sie negieren oder nicht der ist
vorhanden und werden nicht inhaltlich
zusammen mit klugen kompromissen
der ist nicht geeignet diese partei
wieder nach oben zufällig habe die
diskussion sowieso bisher auch nicht
verstanden also einerseits heißt das es
muss eine klare richtungsentscheidung
geben gleichzeitig darf keine risse
entstehen widerspricht sich das nicht
wenn ich mich für eine richtung
entscheiden bedeutet das ja dass die
anderen möglicherweise enttäuscht sind
dass der restliche noch verzeihen das
widerspricht einander nicht denn eine
freiheitliche demokratie ist aufgebaut
auf streit aus streit heraus erkennt man
wo man schnittmengen hat wo etwas
vernünftiger ist als die alternative
position
die vorstellung dass man nur dann
integriert wird und den streit vermeidet
hat sich zwar im deutschen regierung
stehen während nun viele jahre so
durchgesetzt ist aber gleichwohl falsch
freiheit beruht auf pluralistischen
streit und die cdu war immer dann stark
wenn sie in sich zwischen ihren sagen
wir mal drei flügeln oder drei
gruppierungen streit geführt hat wenn
die konservativen mit der liberalen mit
dem herz jesu sozialisten gestritten
haben dann kann man auch ein florales
politik angebot machen dass viele leute
bindet es ist eben die engführung die
vermeidung von streit in der cdu wird
diese partei in den zustand des
heruntergewirtschaftet 1 geführt aber
ist es denkbar dass in einer partei
personen wie daniel günther oder herr
maßen gemeinsam politik markus ist
streiten haben wir gleich um eine
politik machen die man so dass wir
händchen halten und uns noch keine
meinung hat kommen sie kennen doch die
steigung feind todfeind parteifreund das
muss man dann eben aushalten dann müssen
manche leute die ständig als quertreiber
auftreten auch mal kalt gestellt werden
und die anderen müssen sich
zusammenraufen und manch andere müssen
mit zusammengebissenen zähnen halt
manche schauspieler dulden oder besser
nicht stattfände wenn man so viel jetzt
nehmen würde die synode rettungsmission
da gibt es zehn cdu politikern
funktionären ämter die zehn verschiedene
meinungen dazu ich glaube schon du
kannst den streit nur zu bestimmten maß
ertragen muss grundsätzliche positionen
durchziehen und mit einer natürlichen
autorität kraft amt oder im
charismatischer führungsqualität dann
auch durchhalten können es gibt
positionen die sind nicht geklärt die
entschuldigung aber seit nach dem streit
muss mit dem schneiden aber die wir
schon bestreitet der streit noch seit
jahren immer die gleichen themen ja aber
nicht innerhalb der union zb der streit
um seenot rettungsaktionen außengrenze
der eu ist im wesentlichen ein streit
zwischen allen parteien und der bösen
afd
innerhalb der parteien hat seehofer eine
zeit lang versucht hat die csu eine zeit
lang versucht hier den streit zu einem
bestimmten ergebnis zu führen
sie sind unter dem geballten apfel feuer
von medien und politischen gegner
verstummt so dass eben wie sie zu recht
sein
diese thematik an den an tischen des
landes weiter thematisiert wird aber
ansonsten ist man zufrieden dass die
klima thematik sich wie eine decke um
darüber gelegt also ich versuche jetzt
ganz heftig gedanklich mitzuhalten mit
der diskussion also man streitet erst
innerhalb der partei und dann gibt es
einen beschluss
das heißt aber das wird ihre internet
und zusammenführen dann kommt es nicht
an uns dass wir den promis dass man eher
gut ein komponist ihrem außerdem soll
also wie das auch zu hören war jetzt den
letzten tagen die ränder wieder
zusammenführen dann am ende zum beispiel
herrn günther und die werte union
bleiben wir bei diesen extrem fällen
wollen die das überhaupt diese länder in
der cdu da in einem kompromiss
zusammengeführt werden es hätten sie ja
schon längst alles machen können auch
unter einer vorsitzenden ak
also ich meine es gibt immer extrem
positionen in allen parteien und ich
halte im übrigen auch die werte union
für völlig überbewertet weil die im
parteileben der cdu im prinzip gar keine
rolle spielt also so häufig wie die
werte union in den medien ist
da wundere ich mich jedes mal dass ich
kaum bei irgendeiner veranstaltung
jemanden sehe ja kann man kann man auch
sie haben auch gesehen
ja es ist weniger als ein prozent der
gesamten auch hin und wieder haben
einige kreisverbände cdu mehr
mitgliedern also nur mal um vergleich
heranzuziehen aber aber das deutsche der
entscheidende aber der entscheidende
punkt ist doch kann man die
unterschiedlichen strömungen richtungen
miteinander in einklang bringen und
nehmen wir mal das beispiel worüber wir
auch im moment diskutieren klimaschutz
wirtschaftspolitik da haben wir
natürlich wirtschaftspolitiker in der
cdu die sagen es darf keine
deindustrialisierung geben wir sind ein
starker automobilstandort der
wirtschaftsstandort muss gestärkt werden
und dann gibt es andererseits auch
konservative und ökologisch bewusste die
sagen wir müssen natürlich unbedingt die
klimaschutzziele erreichen
und warum verbinde ich das nicht indem
ich zum beispiel in neue technologien
investieren wie wasserstoff konnte wie
synthetische kraftstoffe das überhaupt
kein content wir haben hier im bundestag
darüber heftige diskussionen zwischen
sage ich entwickle ich entwickle hier
diese technologien schaffe arbeitsplätze
und macht damit zum beispiel ein
klimaschutz zum exportschlager das im
übrigen dann auch ein anderer ansatz als
die grünen verfolgen weil ich auch zu
denjenigen gehöre in der cdu die sagen
wir dürfen bei diesem thema den grünen
nicht hinterherlaufen
die wollen nämlich eher über verbote
kommen und über gängelung ich habe ja
die diskussion im bundestag auch häufig
erlebt wie möglich so kann man glaube
ich die unterschiedlichen milieus auch
gut zusammen führen und das hat die
union ja immer stark gemacht wenn man
das geschafft hat das muss kein
widerspruch zur gretchenfrage ist der
umgang mit der afg nicht eine
wirtschaftsorientierte technologieoffene
klimaschutz polizei eine wichtige frage
ich sage nur ich glaube dass ich
beobachten oder sie sind der cdu
politiker ich beobachtet und ich glaube
das ist die gretchenfrage in der cdu an
allen stammtischen in allen mitgliedern
vereinen wo wir teilnehmer sind und
beobachter da wird das diskutiert ich
glaube nicht dass die klimaschutz ist
auch nicht die wachstumspolitik der soli
aber am ende ist es diese frage wie gehe
ich mit der afg und deren
lieblingsthemen um die ungeklärte das zu
sehr unterschätzt auf den oberen ebenen
der partei wir wissen ja dass in
bundesländern wie sachsen anhalt wie
thüringen es auf dieser
kreisverbandsebene der jede menge
kontakte gibt da hört man auch immer
wieder dass die leute sagen wieso sollen
wir mit der afg in bestimmten phasen
nicht kooperieren da scheint das ja
selbstverständlich zu sein ich denke das
ist ein punkt wo von der politik
beziehungsweise von den politikern klare
haltung gefragt ist natürlich ist es so
dass war ja auch jetzt letzte woche in
thüringen erfahren dass es alles nach
regeln der der demokratie
beziehungsweise des parlamentarismus
abgelaufen ist auch auf kommunaler ebene
arbeitet man ja nach regeln der
demokratie zusammen
aber man muss auch ganz sich ganz
darüber im klaren sein wofür die afg vor
allem auch die afg im osten steht und da
gilt es einfach haltung zu zeigen
da gilt es da und da muss die
parteiführung das hat meiner ansicht
nach frau kramp karrenbauer sehr
deutlich gemacht sie es mich gehört
worden aber man kann ihr nicht vorwerfen
vorwerfen dass sie da nicht klare worte
gefunden hat eine haltung zeigen eine
linie auf schreiten über die man aber
die haben wir ja auch mit ganz vielen
beschlüssen gezogen diese linie also sie
haben partei dass beschlüsse in denen
ganz klar drin schon mitte auf die
gibt's keine kooperation und
zusammenarbeit ich komme gerade aus der
bundestagsfraktion
da haben wirklich alle abgeordneten
gesagt mit dfb darf es keine kooperation
geben das ist für uns wirklich
konstitutiv und ein elementares ja
deswegen braucht es ja diese rote linie
aufgezeigt wird und jetzt komme ich
wieder zurück auf das was herr patzelt
gesagt hat eben auch eine eine
führungspersönlichkeit league war dass
das ist der entscheidende punkt
das ist einmal das ich glaube aber
wirklich nicht dass es irgendwo eine
größere mehrheit in der cdu gibt die
seit sie möchte mit der fdp zusammen
aber ich bin ja auch wirklich viel
logischer weise in der partei und treffe
viele und bin in der bundestagsfraktion
da treffen sie wirklich 99 prozent auch
wenn dieser mit dfb darf es keine
kooperation geben weiß eine zum teil
nationalistische und rassistische
parteilos aber aber ich glaube eine
andere frage ist noch viel wichtiger
kann es gelingen die afg auch wieder
kleiner zu machen und wähler
zurückzugewinnen die aus protest ab b
gewählt haben ich merke dass ich an
meiner wahlkreisarbeit auch da kommen
leute zu einem die im prinzip wirklich
weit weg davon sind irgendwie neonazis
zu sagen die sagen wir wollen protest
ausdrücken
wir wollen auch dass die cdu vielleicht
wie das wertkonservative stärker betont
und das müssen wir personell und
inhaltlich schaffen diese menschen
wieder zurück zu bringen jetzt kann
bundestagsfraktion natürlich viel
beschließen zu afd dann müssten sich die
nacht unter den gliederungen der cdu
auch daran halten aber ich nehme gerne
auf was ich jetzt gerade gesagt haben
gibt es eine chance für die cdu das
wählerischer war der afg dass er zu
einem nicht unerheblichen teil aus der
cdu stammt so auszuplündern dass die cdu
wieder stärker wird
ich glaube dass auf absehbare zeit
dieses fenster der gelegenheit dieses
fenster der möglichkeit geschlossen ist
der punkt ist der dass man natürlich mit
der inzwischen so toxisch gewordenen afd
als cdu nicht zusammen wirken kann
es wird es sogar schon zum problem wenn
die afg nur cdu positionen zustimmt da
entsteht ja schon eindruck der müsse die
cdu diese position räumen weil sie doch
deckungsgleich mit der afg sei das heißt
die cdu muss einen großen graben sich
zwischen sich und der afg zehn grad auf
landesebene das aber treibt die cdu
schwach wie sie geworden ist gerade im
osten geradewegs in bündnisse mit den
grünen und den sozialdemokraten hinein
die große sozusagen animosität im
deutschen parteiensystem ist zwischen
denen die den grünen anhängern und denen
die da fdp-anhängern infolgedessen
treiben genau die jetzt notwendig werden
in china koalitionen treibt genau die
hoffnung der cdu gemeinsam mit den
grünen eine zukunftsorientierte politik
der mitte machen zu können
mehr und mehr leute dfb zu deswegen habe
ich ja schon für sehr fragwürdig
gehalten dass friedrich merz gemeint hat
bloß weil er parteivorsitzender wird
oder wenn ihr parteivorsitzender würde
könne die stimmenanteile der afg
halbieren ich glaube dass die fehler der
vergangenheit nämlich das ausgrenzen
ehemaliger cdu das schüren der
erbitterung über die cdu dass das dazu
geführt hat dass ein großer teil der fdp
wählerschaft so schnell nicht mehr für
die cdu reich bürger wenn es aber
vergeblich scheint den ehemaligen
cdu-wählern die jetzt als die wellen
nach zu laufen und man gleichzeitig aber
dass immer wieder versucht und dann auf
der anderen seite des spektrums der cdu
an die grünen zum beispiel dass es ja
auch passiert weder verliert dann könnte
die cdu dennoch weiter erodieren aber
ich teile die einschätzung von attac
zählt nicht kann sich war lange zeit in
nordrhein westfalen tätig und journalist
und hat dort erlebt wie armin laschet
als nrw cdu vorsitzende völlig
unterstützt auch von journalisten mit
einem klaren programm proaktiv die cdu
in der mitte positioniert hat und dann
aber auch in den kernbereichen wo die
afg ihre themen sucht klare politik
gemacht dann um den dfb hinterher zu
laufen aber ich kann doch nicht sagen
wenn ein fdp abgeordneter im bundestag
vorschlägt 100 milliarden euro in dem
schulsystem zu geben und in die bildung
kann ich ja nicht per se sagen das ist
bescheuert nur weil es eine half dem
iran vorgeschlagen
insofern kann ich muss mich auf meine
themen konzentrieren die klar setzen
dort glaubwürdigkeit haben dann kommen
auch auf die wähler zurück ich sagt
niemand dass man mit der afg kooperieren
muss auch in der cdu kenne ich niemanden
das wirklich will
aber man muss trotzdem versuchen die
wählerschaft zurückzuholen durch
glaubwürdige klare politik auch im
bereich der inneren sicherheit auch im
bereich der migration
auch im bereich der wirtschaftspolitik
halt durch was du versprochen was über
jahre über monate und seine glaubwürdige
persönlichkeit beides zusammen bringt
afd wähler zurück da bin ich von der
darin das predige ich ja seit vielen
jahren dass die cdu die position und
gesetzen müsste die den abwandernden
jetztigen afd will und am herzen liegen
sofort kommt aber dann immer und das
wird weiter so sein
der kritikpunkt damit liefe man doch
faktisch kfd nachhaltig beziehe ihre
positionen dann würden die leute das
original wählen und nicht die cdu als
kopie als ob eine partei die keine 77
jahre alt ist im vergleich der sieben
jahrzehnte alten partei jemals das
original sein könnte sie haben ja recht
das von jährlich 1 7 millionen aber sie
ist in den letzten jahren medial nicht
durchsetzbar gewesen auch politisch
nicht durchsetzbar gewesen sollte sich
das ändern wäre wenig werden weniger
leute glücklicher als wir zwei okay
neues spiel neues glück dränge mich für
diese wunderbaren stichworte
herr patzelt wenn man jetzt diese skizze
wie zukunft die cdu wieder zum erfolg
geführt werden kann wer von den
verdächtigen könnte das am besten oder
sehen sie doch noch kein die drei
üblichen verdächtigen sind die drei
herren aus nordrhein westfalen es wird
jetzt natürlich er immer herr laschet
als derjenige dargestellt mit den
meisten chancen wohlgemerkt es ist der
nicht kandidat ist der einzige der sich
noch nicht ins rennen geworfen hat jens
jens spahn und friedrich merz haben das
ja schon einmal getan ich glaube das
hängt auch ganz stark davon ab welches
wie eigentlich gewählt wird und wer
wählt also bei einer mitgliederbefragung
was die cdu wahrscheinlich nicht machen
wird genau würde es würde es friedrich
merz ein parteitag würde herr laschet
man muss sich jetzt auch mal überlegen
der nächste parteivorsitzende wird
garantiert nicht noch einmal diese
spagat machen dass frau kramp
karrenbauer versucht hat mit einer
kanzlerin merkel
also man muss es einfach mal
durchspielen frau merkel würde die trans
lacht übergeben was ja geht das heißt
vom parlament ist parlament würde einen
kanzler wiederwählen
das kann eigentlich mit der gruppe nur
herr laschet sein jemand anderes würde
würde die spd nicht wenn der preis für
jens spahn wäre enorm hoch würde die spd
das überhaupt machen natürlich nicht die
welt auch nicht in kanzler genau ein
kanzler um dann gegen den neuen panzer
in den wahlkampf zu ziehen und
andererseits und dann höre ich dann höre
ich auch auf bei allen drei kandidaten
so ganz ehrlich der große charismatische
ruck der große wurf in die zukunft sehe
ich beim 1
sie sind jetzt bis ans ende der welt
umfasst geflitzt müssten gedanken gleich
alles noch mal ein rückschritt noch die
noch partei vorsitzende annegret kramp
karrenbauer hatte er gestern gesagt sie
möchte die kür des kanzlerkandidaten und
späteren parteivorsitzenden von vorne
führen wie sie gesagt hat so bis zum
sommer und dann in den herbst hinein
dann gibt es dann irgendwann den
regulären parteitag in stuttgart glaube
ich im dezember
das klingt alles nach einem
kontemplativen erweckung seminar für das
genauso ablaufen oder geht das alles
viel schneller also es darf aus meiner
sicht keine monatelange hängepartie
geben sondern wir müssen spätestens bis
zum sommer entscheidung fällen wo soll
es inhaltlich mit der cdu hin gehen aber
wir müssen auch bis zum sommer die
personelle neuaufstellung abgeschlossen
haben und ich glaube dass friedrich merz
tatsächlich eine zentrale rolle spielen
muss wir merken dass wir bei ganz vielen
veranstaltungen die im land durchführt
da sind die hallen wirklich über voll
die leute drängen sich hin
die umfragen zeigen dass er mit abstand
der beliebteste cdu-politiker neben der
kanzlerin ist und ihm würden die meisten
menschen zutrauen kann zu sein ich
glaube auch dass ich ein sparende
wichtige rolle spielen muss man da auch
für die zukünftigen generationen
natürlich eine wichtige rolle spielen
kann aber auch personen wie carsten
linnemann
sollte man wirklich nicht unterschätzen
da haben wir auch wirklich gerade was
die jüngere generation an ich glaube ich
einige sehr gute leute und wenn wir das
hinbekommen diese personen zusammen zu
führen dass das jetzt nicht in einen
monatelangen kampf ausartet sondern sich
zu einem team formt dann kann die cdu
wieder richtig stark werden und dann
kann sie auch glaubhaft wähler aus
nichtwählerlager zurückhole tieren da
haben wir nämlich auch millionen cdu hin
verloren von der fdp zurückgewinnen und
auch einige grüne denn ich glaube wenn
man eine gute wirtschaftspolitik mit
einer guten klimaschutzpolitik
kombiniert dann wird man da gerade auch
in der großstadt sehr erfolgreich sagt
meine nicht zu erinnern dass ich am
anfang von der quadratur des kreises
gesprochen habe bei der begrüßung
moderation klingt jetzt ein bisschen
wird auf eines eines auf jeden fall
nicht mehr machen triumphierte oder
troika das in der geschichte aber
sicherlich das meine ich jetzt eine
korrelation ist eher müßig die drei
werden sich sicherlich zusammensetzen
vielleicht sind die von irgendeiner
raststätte in castro muss nun machen
dass gerade ich weiß es nicht
spannend wird es aber die drei sind
schon im lied wenn es schneller gehen
muss dann müsste es ja wahrscheinlich
auch einen sonderparteitag geben
irgendwann in nicht allzu ferner zukunft
vielleicht im sommer und dann stellt
sich die frage die formelle schon hier
eingebracht hat wie lange geht es dann
gut mit dem neuen vorsitzenden der noch
kanzlerkandidat ist der dann
möglicherweise 15 monate noch warten
muss bis es richtig losgeht der sich
prächtig entwickeln kann der aber auch
sich verschließen kann dafür gibt es
auch beispiele in der geschichte nicht
unbedingt der cdu
stichwort wie geht man in angela merkel
um in welchem dilemma ist die cdu dann
hat sie die führungsfrage gelöst aber
dann gibt es ja noch andere angela
merkel
was wird da passieren was kann da
passieren was muss passieren oder ist es
tatsächlich denkbar dass die
legislaturperiode normal zu ende geht
also eine kohabitation sozusagen
zwischen der kanzlerin merkel und einem
späteren kanzler kandidaten kann nur
kurzfristig gut gehen man kann natürlich
die kanzlerin nicht während der
deutschen präsidentschaft in der eu
auswechseln dh wenn nicht die kanzlerin
vor dem krönenden abschluss ihrer
europapolitischen tätigkeit was die
präsidentschaft sein wird das amt
verlassen sollte wird es so sein dass
bei einer frühzeitigen aus wahl des
neuen cdu parteivorsitzenden man ein
halbes jahr lang koexistenz merkel und
kanzlerkandidat haben wird und das kann
große reibungen geben
die ließen sich lediglich dadurch
abfedern dass die kanzlerin in aller
klarheit erklärt nach dem ende der
deutschen präsidentschaft würde sie das
kanzleramt verlassen dann taucht aber
das nächste problem auf einesteils ein
persönliches mit großer freude würde
angela merkel ausgerechnet das
kanzleramt friedrich merz übergeben und
das andere ist das ja erst nicht so ist
als ob der kanzler einfach seine
nachfolge bestimmen könnte und der wäre
es dann
es muss der bundestag den wählern und
wie es vorhin zu recht gesagt worden ist
dass der spd friedrich merz welt ja das
würde der dortigen konfus und ein
professor im einsatz dazu sagen der weg
den es dann gibt nachdem wir inzwischen
die verfassung
möglichkeiten austesten ist natürlich
eine wahl im bundestag werde erst keine
absolute mehrheit für den kandidaten
gibt dann kommt im dritten wahlgang der
wievielte es auch immer ist aber nach
zwei wochen nach dem ersten wahlgang
gibt es einen in dem die relative mehr
zählt und dann kann der bundespräsident
den bundestag auflösen und das heißt im
schlimmsten fall könnten wir im januar
im februar im märz die neuwahlen haben
soll jetzt hier der name laschet schon
gefallen der einzige den die spd noch
einmal mit wählen würde aber die wirte
ja einen kanzler wählen dann im
bundestagswahlkampf gegen die spd
antritt mit einem gewissen amtsbonus
also ist eigentlich nur der weg denkt
bei den professor passiv gerade
geschildert hat ich für ausgeschlossen
dass die spd einen anderen kanzler noch
die möglichkeit gibt aus dem amt heraus
wahlkampf zu führen die schauen sich das
doch gerade ganz genüsslich an wie die
sich da zurecht ruckeln und ich glaube
auch dass vor der eu ratspräsidentschaft
so etwas nicht passieren wird auch
angela merkel hat noch ihre truppen in
der partei wenn ich an die
sozialverbände denke wenn ich an die
frauen-union denke wenn ich an ein paar
landesverbände denken die werden das so
schnell nicht zulassen
ich glaube auch armin laschet weiß dass
der vielleicht ein bisschen das führen
könnte dieses diese diese struktur mit
den anderen landesverbänden sich ja
gerade ab spricht deswegen ich glaube
auch wir reden über anfang 2021 und im
vorfeld vielleicht die entscheidung da
ist es ja wohl kaum denkbar dass es was
sie gesagt haben so schnell geht das man
noch vor der eu präsidentschaft diesen
wechsel vornimmt denn dann hätte der
neue präsident ist ja mit 26 egomanen zu
tun und müsste sich da erst mal ein
fuchs das heißt also rechnen sie auch
mit einer bundestagswahl im ersten
quartal 2021 da also damit rechne ich im
moment überhaupt nicht das ist auch ganz
viel spekulation also ich habe in dieser
legislaturperiode schon so viel erlebt
alles war er sich also eine von mir
gesagt die spekulation sei die frage wie
lang kann ist zu dieser koexistenz oder
kohabitation zwischen der kanzlerin und
einem kanzlerkandidaten jahres profis
die dann auch professionell
zusammenarbeiten da haben wir davon
nicht geschafft deswegen haben wir ja
das problem glaube ich gerade aber es
ist wirklich also ganz viel spekulation
ich glaube auch dass die menschen ein
bundestag gewählt haben wo sie von den
abgeordneten erwarten dass die probleme
im land
lösen wie können wir zum beispiel
schneller infrastruktur projekte planen
und bauen nicht klimaschutzziele
erfüllen die grenzen sichern
und dass wir nicht die ganze zeit
darüber reden wann wen wer neu war dass
sehr viele nervt also insofern ich bin
bereit bis zum ende legislatur
technologie zwei erstens soll die große
coco muss noch einiges aufarbeiten in
der tat sie soll ja regieren
andererseits haben ja wenn ich mir die
umfragen an sie hier selbst die besten
für spd union glaube ich keine der
beiden parteien wirklich interesse dass
es relativ schnell zu einer
bundestagswahl kommt genau so dass das
heißt wie das ist einfach aber es gibt
ein weiteres dilemma dann man kann diese
koexistenz sich ewig führen aber der
ausstieg aus der groko ist auch nicht so
richtig gut daher möglicherweise dann
stattfinden würde wenn es zu neuwahlen
käme vielleicht noch mal was sie gesagt
haben im dritten wahlgang genügt die
relative mehrheit aber dann ist die
entscheidung bei bundespräsident diese
im kopf habe er kann sagen okay
minderheiten kanzler machen war noch
oder er sagt nie machen wir nicht das
ist nämlich eine seiner wenigen wirklich
politische entscheidungen und dann gibt
es neuwahlen spannenden könnte natürlich
sein wenn in hamburg für die spd gar
nicht so schlecht aus wie man denken
könnte und dass er eine art scholz
wahlkampf wäre denn das ist eine politik
die dort gemacht wurde und jetzt
umgesetzt würde es die spd vorzieht und
den kanzlerkandidaten zb olaf scholz
nach hamburg nominiert und den druck auf
die cdu erhöht das würde auch noch mal
spannend aber dass bei ihm haben aber
die hamburger parteifreunde von hand
bloß nicht wenn sie haben ja auch schon
vor thüringen glaube ich die
landtagswahl verloren gegeben
das würde ich so nie sagen und die
erwartungen habe so dass wir in hamburg
auch schon mal eine bessere situation
hatten das völlig klar
aber wir sind da wirklich hoch motiviert
und arbeiten
die cdu jedenfalls nicht weiter belasten
egal wie es in hamburg ausgeht könnte
dann nicht mehr möglich aber immer auch
eine lokal spezifische wahl gewesen also
sowohl in guten als auch in schlechten
zeiten
deswegen würde ich nochmal holen wollen
die bohrinsel der dass sogar die
absolute mir erst hat das damals so da
waren wir im bund auch schwächer und
hatten dann in hamburg die absolute
mehrheit also das ist wirklich immer
getrennt zu betrachten lassen den ganz
kurzen blick noch auf die spd werfen
die hat er im moment so was wie eine
verschnaufpause
die wird nicht ewig anhalten was ist
dann mit der ist wie ich meine jetzt
nicht nur was ihre sie hat sich ja zur
coco nochmal bekannt sondern ich meine
eigentlich wie sie mit ihren
führungsproblemen die ja auch nicht
gelöst sind weiter umgeht
sie haben vollkommen recht die spd ist
endlich mal ist aus perspektive der spd
endlich mal nicht im rampenlicht ist
über nichts gestolpert gerade sondern
kann sich sortieren
klar ist dass die führungsfrage und auch
die kanzlerkandidatenfrage in keinster
weise geklärt sind und jetzt ist das
junge duo ja noch nicht so lange im amt
aber ich rechne auch da eigentlich mit
der nächsten führungskrise
weil das du in keinster weise in der
lage ist die spd wieder so auf spur zu
bringen inhaltlich so aufzustellen
die es für den wahlkampf 20 21 sein dass
das heißt man muss sich bei den beiden
die bundesregierung stellen denn oder
drei jahren entscheidung nicht die csu
sehr komme gleich nochmal bei spd und
cdu darauf einstellen oder dran gewöhnen
dass die im permanenten führungskrise
sind haben das leiden werden sie haben
gerade gesagt wer hätte gedacht dass wir
in dieser sendung mal sagen würde die
csu ist der letzte stabilitätsanker
menschen koalition
wir sehen jetzt meine beendet ich wollte
nämlich sagen für das war jahren werde
man ausgelacht worden sind mir gesagt
hatte ich csu ist der stabilitätsfaktor
der koalition aber gut wenn wir dafür
schon dabei sind
wir haben jetzt über markus söder noch
nicht gesprochen doch mehrfach und
wahrscheinlich auch glaubhaft versichert
er will ich kann es da kann die seite ja
aber was ist von ihm
dazu erwarten jetzt einerseits in bezug
auf die schwesterpartei cdu da der ja
schon eine menge ratschläge in den
letzten tagen gegeben aber andererseits
auch was die stabilität der groko angeht
und damit ja eigentlich auch die
stabilität unseres parteiensystems
also ich würde mal ganz kurz zu sagen
auf jeden fall wieder angerufen werden
jetzt er will derjenige sein der
mitgeholfen hat die cdu wieder in ruhige
bahnen sollen alleine das gefühl dass er
vielleicht jetzt auch sehr schnell mit
armin laschet dem wichtigsten
landesvorsitzenden der cdu spricht
könnte ich mir vorstellen
er hat ja auch schon angekündigt das
kabinett muss
also er treibt gerne von münchen die
bundespolitik anja und inszeniert sich
sehr als derjenige der ruhe und frieden
ist trotzdem in seinem traumjob den er
gar nicht aufgeben will also korrigieren
sie mich also ich glaube da von markus
söder ist er ein wenig druck auf berlin
zu erwarten aber kein echtes eine
scheiße markus söder empfindet jetzt die
arbeit die er in berlin mit den beiden
partnern noch mal so als betreutes
koalieren
das eine sehr schöne formulierungen die
ich gerne über den mann werde
ansonsten ist halt der csu und einem
ganz anderen existenziellen druck als
die cdu die sich viele fisimatenten
leisten kann die ganze machte csu hängt
davon ab dass sie in bayern die
dominante regierungspartei ist infolge
des muss die csu wesentlich intensiver
auf umschichtungen von vela präferenzen
und so weiter gehen als andere parteien
und das macht nun wieder in einer sehr
effektiven weisen den gründern im der
dass bienen thema weg er in gestalt der
freien wähler koaliert damit sich selbst
vertritt dann auch noch unter dem
windschatten dass er ja ein grünes thema
nun sich zu eigen gemacht hat auch noch
position und die zuvor manche leute zur
afg vertrieben haben sollen sich im
licht des lobes er zeige wie man die afg
klein halten kann
das heißt er lässt sich auf die sorgen
und anliegen der bürgerschaft eingreift
sie mit zumindest tatkräftig erscheint
und der politik vielleicht auch mit
wirklich tatkräftiger politik auf und
zeigt auf diese weise so zumindest ein
anspruch der cdu wird es eigentlich
ginge ja eben klingt eher nach einer
stellenbeschreibung für den idealen cdu
vorsitzenden
wie sehen sie die die die zusammenarbeit
mit der csu im moment ich mag ja die hat
man die zusammenarbeit hat sich in den
vergangenen monaten immer besser auch
entwickelt und sie haben eben zu recht
gesagt vor zwei jahren da hatten wir
durchaus unsere schwierigkeiten und ganz
andere diskussion räumen gewesen und es
läuft wirklich sehr gut und ich sage
auch als cdu-politiker man kann im
moment von der csu einiges lernen weil
die csu glaube ich sehr wichtige große
themen der zeit modernen aufgreift
einerseits sagen sie bei der inneren
sicherheit bei der migrationspolitik da
muss es klare linien geben nicht die
grenzen müssen noch stärker gesichert
werden ist muss kontrolliert werden wer
ins land kommt trotzdem will man
qualifizierte fachkräfte gewinnen die
die unternehmen dringend brauchen
da haben sie richtig klare linien
reingebracht und sie nehmen
auch die themen wie klimaschutz oder
auch gute ernährung oder bienen auf die
gerade in den großstädten natürlich
zunehmend eine rolle spielen und zeigen
dass man das miteinander verbinden und
verknüpfen kann und damit sowohl die fdp
klar machen kann als auch dafür sorgen
kann dass sich zb ökologisch bewusste
großstädter angesprochen führen und das
wäre glaube ich auch ein modell was wir
als cdu vielleicht noch stärker auf also
100 csu lernen heißt siegen lernen das
kommt immer wieder die
evolutionsforschung der ja durchaus
neigungen auch in die damals
existierende ddr gehabt dass er so
schnell vorgeprescht ist am tag der wahl
in thüringen nach gefühlten 30 minuten
vor allen anderen er hat natürlich auch
leicht denn er hat in thüringen keine
aktien drin er konnte natürlich schon
eher politisch wie ein rohrspatz
schimpfen auf das was damals hatte er es
leicht weil er tatsächlich nur zuschauer
gewesen ist zum anderen hat er mit
seinem untrüglichen politischen instinkt
erkannt dass hier einfach eine
nachgerade innerpolitische
nuklearkatastrophe geschehen ist und
hier dann der grundsatz gilt rette sich
wer kann
und obendrein hat er angesichts des
medialen und politischen drucks auf
distanz suchen zur afd gleich die
richtige bewegung gemacht nämlich weit
weg es darf keine zusammenarbeit geben
und so steht er als ein inbegriff eines
vernünftigen unionspolitikers dar
dem könnten sich ja auch manche cdu
kreisverbände in ostdeutschland zum
beispiel auch ein beispiel nehmen da
eine klare distanz zu als die
herzustellen oder ist es einfach halte
ich für absolut notwendig also ich hatte
es ja auch am anfang der sendung gesagt
also wir müssen eine ganz klare grenze
zur afg ziehen auch zur linkspartei das
halte ich nach wie vor für wirklich
wichtig und das geht natürlich nicht nur
hier für die bundes-cdu oder hierfür die
bundestagsfraktion sondern auch für
jeden landesverband der cdu völlig klar
hält diese grund diese linie noch lange
gegen die linkspartei wo man jetzt sagt
den spielleuten die ramelow
da könnt ihr eigentlich nicht so tun als
seien das quasi das gleiche dürfte also
ich finde die die cdu wäre gut daran
beraten zu erkennen dass sie dass die
distanz zur linkspartei eine ganz andere
ist als die cfd und dass man natürlich
auf jetzt was die linkspartei
auf länder ebene anbelangt das ist dass
das eine andere partei ist als die als
auf bundesebene und dann als ausrede mit
der annahme und wenn sie beide wenn sie
beide mauern aufrechterhält raucht sie
sich jeglicher machtoption und das kann
eine partei mit zeit lang machen
aber irgendwann das große dilemma der
spd irgendwann muss man dem wähler auch
wieder eine macht hier hat er ein
problem da wo sie leben hier
wir haben einfach wählen wir sind am
ende nicht wir aber die sendung
ich bedanke mich dass sie da waren für
dieses thema und das ist sicherlich
kündige ich öfter in einer sendung an
noch lange beschäftigen das aber ganz
bestimmt in allen facetten morgen in der
phoenix runde das thema katerstimmung in
berlin
überforderte politiker verteilt die
bürger bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]